[Music]
a new space race is brewing in corporate
America SpaceX is scheduled to launch
its 16th cargo supply mission to the
International Space Station later today
it wants to become the first company to
carry astronauts to the station as soon
as next summer but so does Boeing both
companies will operate competing space
taxis for NASA ending 7 years of relying
on Russia for rides to space mark
Strassmann met two astronauts who will
fly for the rival companies in an
out-of-this-world game of capture the
flag and liftoff the final liftoff of
Atlantis when the space shuttle roared
toward the sky for the last time it
carried a special payload a small
American flag the cruise intending to
leave that flag onboard the
International Space Station and 250
miles above Earth Shuttle commander
Chris Ferguson led the ceremony this
flag represents not just a symbol of our
national pride and honor but in this
particular case it represents a goal the
next astronaut that launched from
American soil that docked to the space
station would get to bring the flag home
did you ever think when he left the flag
that the person who might take it up
could be you absolutely not I was
absolutely certain that I was never
going back to space again
but Ferguson will ride a rocket again
this time as a corporate astronaut for
Boeing we're ready to take America back
into space I think the country has been
missing something
but they don't know they've been missing
it it's been so long now it's inside of
a year and it is real at Boeing's
assembly plant in Florida
Ferguson showed us the spacecraft that
he helped design the Starliner I want to
get the seats in there I want to get the
floor clothes out when it's ready this
capsule will carry Ferguson and NASA
astronauts Nicole Mann and Eric BOE on
its first trip into orbit flying their
autonomously where it will dock with the
space station Ferguson could recover the
same flag he left there seven years ago
what would that be like I think it'll be
anticlimactic I think it'll be largely
symbolic in nature oh come on
okay it'll be cool very cool
but SpaceX Boeing's competitor could
beat him to it
NASA astronauts Bob Behnken and Doug
Hurley will be the first to fly SpaceX
is sleek new ship called crew dragon we
will dock the Commercial Crew vehicles
to the front of the space station just
like we did with shuttle we met Hurley
at the Johnson Space Center in Houston
at NASA's training mock-up of the space
station we'd be floating which is a lot
more fun that would be more fun it's
really knows about the flag up there
because he flew it there he piloted the
last shuttle flight and this hatch was
closed and we left the flag right up
there I didn't think I was gonna fly
again let alone be potentially the guy
that goes up and gets it maybe it's I
stole sometimes have a hard time
believing it it's sort of ironic I guess
how this all played out nobody ever
really saw this coming so how important
is it for you and not Doug Hurley with
SpaceX to grab that flag I would never
admit it to him but I would say it's
very important to me he knows it too I
have no problem with a little healthy
competition it makes you better and it
makes him better and it makes both
companies better and in the end who
benefits the country you know we get
redundant access to space in the end it
doesn't really matter who gets the flag
it matters that somebody gets it
absolutely and they come back two
astronauts who closed the last chapter
of American space flight now find
themselves competing to open the next
one for CBS this morning
mark Strassmann at the Kennedy Space
Center mmm
race to the final frontier competition
is always good but it's really good when
you win you say yes it's good whoever
wins it's okay you always want to win
and you want that you won't be competing
with anybody to get the first ride on
that taxi nope sir I'll be cheering you
on though John
shotgun